en suède celui qui s'est occupé de ces
mesures de prendre ces mesures afin
qu'il a justifié ces mesures
c'est en fait le responsable du service
épidémiologie de l' agence de sécurité
quand je dis à jean sécurité sanitaire
c'est pas ça en suède doit ces agences
de santé publique de santé du peuple
et c est lui le directeur du un dr
steiner qui est directeur du service
d'épidémiologie c'est lui qui a tout
pris c'est lui qui a dit il faut faire
ça il faut car il faut voir il faut pas
faire de confinement je prends mes
responsabilités et c'est lui qui s'est
mis en avant et papa le gouvernement le
moment est laissé faire comme nous
évidemment il a consulté des experts
mais que le premier ministre il n'est
jamais apparu presque la muse la santé
on la connaît à peine
mais c'est de ces deux formes de
gouvernement qui sont totalement
différentes de la nôtre
[Musique]